esto de aquí es la sección de ejercicios
para comprender el inverso de una
función y es una sección interactiva en
lo que podemos mover esta línea nos
muestra la gráfica de hdx que es la
línea punteada y tenemos que arrastrar
los extremos del segmento amarillo para
graficar h inversa de x hay varias
maneras de resolver esto quizá la forma
más sencilla es ver de dónde a dónde se
mapea hdx nos dice que hdx es un
segmento que une los puntos 19 y 32 esto
quiere decir que en este punto cuando x
es igual a 1 hd x es 9 por lo que mapea
19 el inverso de esto debe mapear de 9 a
1 así que movamos este punto de aquí
muy bien el otro punto de hdx es x 3 y
hdx dos así que mapea de 3 a 2
por lo que el inverso de esto es mapear
de dos atrás tomamos el otro es punto a
esta posición
con esto hemos encontrado la gráfica
inversa de esta función
otra forma de ver esto es que si
dibujáramos la línea x igual que aquí no
puedo dibujar porque estoy trabajando
con una página web pero si nos
imaginamos la línea x igual a esto de
acá será el reflejo de esto otro de acá
ya que estamos intercambiando las x por
las 10 si dibujáramos esta línea x
y si volteamos este segmento sobre esta
línea x igual allí tendríamos este
segmento de acá éste se voltearía acá y
este otro se voltearía acá de cualquier
forma hemos terminado encontramos la
inversa de hd x